Hello, I'm Danielle Brooks,
and I play Leota Adebayo
on Peacemaker.
-New girl, huh?
-Yeah.
DANIELLE BROOKS:
Leota is a newcomer to the world
of superheroes and metahumans,
so I, Danielle, am gonna try
to dive into some
of the wildest vintage
comic books and see
if I can figure out what
the hell is going on with them.
So the first comic
is Detective Comics.
Definitely, this is Pride month.
Robin is just confused.
He didn't know Batman
was coming out.
I definitely think Batman
should stick with the pink.
It does wonders
for his skin tone.
Now, we are diving
into The Flash.
Did you see what I did there?
I'm gonna take
a wild guess here
and say, well, maybe
they're roleplaying.
She gets excited by being like,
"You're not my husband!
You are my husband!
Oh my gosh, it's a stranger
in my bed!"
I think that's where
this is really going.
Now, we are going
to Superman's Lois Lane.
Lois is getting it in
with Aquaman,
Batman, and Green Arrow.
And that's okay, women,
to liberate yourself.
If you're a single woman,
you have every right
to live your best life.
I'm guessin' Lois
is in her twenties.
Watch Peacemaker
by subscribing to HBO Max.
-Don't do anything stupid.
-No problem.
-I'll ask the questions.
-Fine by me.
You're definitely
gonna be chill?
Fucking chill, dude.
Jesus, relax.
-Hey, no!
-No!
Maybe I should work with the man
who came up with these stories.
Call me.